committee to order 1004 am as chair of
the House Judiciary Committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the colloid nineteen pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number twelve
first su into executive order 2020 - all
for this public body is authorized to
meet electronically please note that
there is no physical location to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting which was authorized pursuant to
the governor's emergency order however
in accordance with the emergency order I
am confirming that we are a providing
public access to the meeting by
telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means we are utilizing zoom
for this electronic meeting all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporary contemporaneously during
this meeting through this platform and
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
clicking in the following website
address here the pencil HTTP colon slash
slash zoom dot u s / j / nine three
seven five three five two eight eight
five four or dialing one of the
following phone numbers 1-99 205 609
nine or one 301 seven one five eight
five nine to be providing public notice
of the necessary information for
assessing the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting including how to
access the meeting using zoom or
telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar see
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there are problems with access if
anyone has a problem please call to 7 1
3 600 or email each CS at ledge state
dot n H dot u.s. D a journey the meeting
if the public is unable to access the
meeting in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and reschedule I want
to introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting us Gen 4 House
Committee researcher is the meeting host
additional House committee services
staff providing support are Brad
Greenland
Pam's Marling and Kristina Dyer this is
an executive session on HB 1642 pursuant
to house rules 46
F I have waived the public hearing on
this bill a work session was held on HB
1642 on May 19th a copy of the bill and
other relevant materials have been
posted on the main page of the General
Court website under the heading remote
meetings please note that all votes
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote I want to stop here
and welcome to our committee this
morning Carol McGuire who is sitting in
for from for mark McClain who was
because of a family situation is not
able to be with us today
now let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance when each member
states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during the
meeting that is required under the right
to know law and the chair now recognizes
representative welfare clerk of the
committee's all right so Matt each are
you here I am here and I am alone ending
11 weeks of being alone location
location let me see if I can say where
but I'm in Durham I'm not recording it
so do I have to record the location in
the alumnus and them in the attendance
sheet I do not believe so and it is not
on the instructions very nice
representative Keys is not with us at
the moment is that right I am here she
is now now representative Burch I'm here
I'm alone and I'm the West Berlin
because I could do that later I
represented Corrigan I'm I'm I'm in
Durham in my office and I'm a my home
office and I'm look alone and no one's
in the room with me representative all
sure I'm here in Stratham in my home
office and my husband will be in and out
his home office too representative
DiLorenzo I'm here at my home in Market
in my home office and I'm alone
representative Burroughs I'm here alone
right now my husband Jonathan will
likely be in and out and I am in
Bartlett representative chest
I'm here I'm alone and I'm in Rollins
burn not work
representative Kenny I'm here in Durham
and I'm alone
representative Langley I'm here I'm in
Manchester and my husband is here I lost
my cursor okay representative Stephens
I'm here Nashua alone
representative Harper I am here my
grandson we'll be in and out I can
assure you he doesn't care about what
we're doing I am and we're represented
Sylvia I'm home alone in Belmont
representative welfare is home alone in
Stratford representative Gordon robux
and if Gordon is not here it's not here
because I put him in the nee call I
don't know how we do this get over there
over there I said never mind that I'll
fix it later represented Cameron he's
not here either
he is here he's on mute at the moment
we're representative Jen can you unmute
yourself King hey can you are we out
there he goes there I'm actually
outdoors so I'm muting myself in between
confident because I'm at the town
library and Seabrook by myself if you
don't count the birds and bees flying
around with my head representing the
Griffin I am here in Goffstown alone
representative of Dwyer I'm here in
Epsom and my husband may be in and out
I'm here alone in Goffstown I don't care
we have everybody here everybody except
Gordon thank you very much did that
style and consonant grace no matter how
hard okay that being the case I opened
up the executive session on House bill
1642 to my understanding only one
amendment has been submitted and I hope
you will correct me if I am wrong about
that the amendment that I have is a 2020
12:55 H submitted by representative
Harper and representative well per would
one of you like to explain the amendment
to the committee and I don't know who
wants to speak first you tell me so
representative father you're the prime
sponsor do you want to go do you want me
to I'm gonna summarize it I'm in a I
really missed the the ladies up on the
fourth floor of the LOB because they
could I could copy stuff and they would
zoom it in and print it out for me and
so I'm looking at tiny little black dots
on my tablet they're very difficult to
read so I'm gonna let representative
well Burt Wolper do most of it but I'll
give you a summary of what we did
basically there was a lot of concerned
about eliminating the use of facial
recognition software entirely and I
think representative birch and others
were concerned
we're concerned that you know very very
bad people won't get caught because we
aren't allowed to use facial recognition
software I tend to disagree but by the
same token I'm only one vote so the
compromise we reach basically is that
all right if facial recognition is used
it can be used but like everything else
you have to have a search warrant
so that's fundamentally the the primary
change of the amendment is so that soft
the technology can be used but it can't
just be arbitrary you know used
hopefully not be abused by requiring a
search warrant before it's used so it
can be still be I believe adequately
used to find the missing child or or any
such case or I think representative
birch were was talking about a facial
recognition software being used to
apprehend somebody in Massachusetts and
then pursuing them in New Hampshire
would that evidence negate the case and
so there's a there's a part in there
that in any amendment that addresses
that so fundamentally I think it the
amendment solves most of the issues that
we had when we had our previous session
I'll turn it over to occur because he he
can actually read while he's talking
thank you before before I recognized
represented well / representative
McGuire has a question yes thank you
madam chair I'm afraid that since I was
a late member I didn't get a copy of the
amendment of my email and I wondered if
I could I can send that right now thank
you okay now representative Welker thank
you madam chair
as we go through this we strip down the
bill quite substantially as Gary
mentioned the bill started out being a
ban on the use of the technology we were
recognizing there's a lot of good uses
to which is put and just like a lot of
things in our world can be put to good
use or bad and it's our business to
restrain the bad so that's what we've
attempted to do so first thing you'll
notice is that the definitions have been
reduced because some of the Thracians
and terminology that we had in the
original bill weren't applicable anymore
so but the remaining definitions are the
same as they were so it basically covers
everybody in the whole state everybody
that's the state or acts for the state
the bulk of the mucus begins on line 15
640 424 face recognition technology
prohibited and it says nobody that is or
was representative state can use any
face recognitions recognition system or
any information obtained from a face
recognition system but it does not
prohibit law enforcement agencies from
lawfully assisting federal agencies that
joint law enforcement which was one of
the major concerns that we had and law
enforcement agency shall not request
encourage suggests or otherwise initiate
access to information or data so so what
we're really saying is that you can
cooperate with other people who use face
for face recognition tools but not
request that they do so not initiate
their doing so we don't want any part of
that but if they're doing it then you
can you can accept that cooperate with
them and use the data to it just for
whatever of lawful purpose you have
which will see as we go forth
6:44 25 evidence inadmissible
I need add a collective this isn't
virtually the same thing as we had
before and the idea of it is that we're
telling you you can't use this in any if
if you're in violation of the
subdivision so that you can't use it in
any kind of proceeding within that
within the state so any hearing any
trial hearing proceeding in any court
grand jury Department officer agency
regulatory body legislative committee
wherever you can't use these things you
can't use that information if it were
obtained in violation of this new
restriction so it's inadmissible and any
any trial very proceeding et cetera to
do okay
and anything shall be considered
unlawfully obtained and shall be
irretrievably deleted if it's your law
unlawfully obtained person aggrieved by
a violation of the subdivision may file
for injunctive relief declaratory wait
this is the same it's just if you have
if your if your rights are being
violated by a violation in this
subdivision that accretes you a private
right of action mine wait a minute where
I get my evidence admissible home any
others derive that our information and
private cause of action
whereas I miss something here in reading
list my screen is doing me doing me bad
are you on the amendment that's what I'm
looking at is he wearing the wrong thing
because I call you several of the points
that you mentioned have been taken I'm
sorry
members okay where's my email
all right I can't so the one is of
actual paper is that you can just
shuffle the papers that's what I'm
trying to do right here I think we're
all in sympathy representative helper
it's very hard this way very hard I
think that the beginning was fine I
think you then got into some points that
have would no longer relevant in the
amendment yeah it's true
basically we've done is we said you can
use it for any legal purpose as long as
you have a warrant and if you if you
don't have it that's the biggest change
in it and and we don't consider the
warrant requirement to be anything
onerous at all police officers there
warrants all the time and in the case of
exigent circumstances they get them in a
matter of minutes so it's something that
law enforcement is very familiar with
and they can use at any time they want
as long as they have a warrant signed by
a judge they get a probable cause
get a warrant from a judge that's what
they always do when they have to do this
type of thing and that's there that's
the part that protects against us
against abuses of the systems we also
all this is a what I call the purge
language which talks about anything
obtained is inadmissible unless it's
sufficiently tennant attenuated from the
event
and all that means is if the information
is out there but it had the way it was
arrived at or derived had nothing at all
to do with the actual event then it
could be admissible I think
representative Burks could probably
explain that better than I can
that's why it's in there because that
was one of his concerns and the last
thing is the Department of Motor
Vehicles where we said that the
department will not allow people to
access their database using this
technology because they already have it
they already have this big database if
you will of fate of faces and we're
trying to protect the people that have
allowed their images to be kept which is
on the vast majority of us from fishing
expeditions so that's pretty much know
the amendment thank you first
represented burrows and then
representative Burke thank you madam
chair
representative well first wondering if
you could tell us which of any
stakeholders were involved in the
preparation of this amendment or who was
who who did you who else might have been
consulted so we really made the
amendment among ourselves we didn't have
a lot of discussion with like Chiefs of
Police or people like that we took the
concerns and the actual process that we
went through is for every concern that
had been raised either in the hearing
itself or in private conversation after
the hearing
we started addressing them one at a time
after a fair amount of that a lot of
changes to the language by various
parties we came to the recognition that
we could really simplify the whole thing
by getting down to this look we
using the technology we don't want to be
in the technology we don't want to
prevent its use for good purposes and we
can do that very simply by saying look
if you're going to use a technology you
have to have a warrant there you go
thank you Burke thank you madam chair
the first thing I want to do is say how
much of an improvement I think the
amendment is over the original bill
clearly is an improvement over the
original bill and I respect that second
point I want to make is whatever answer
representative Walberg gave to
representative burrows no names were
mentioned as to who was actually
consulted or not other than that generic
we I just want to make sure when he
talked about compromise and mentioned my
name a number of times that it's clear I
was not involved in the drafting of this
in putting it together in the language
in negotiation or anything I got this in
the mail and that was the first time
that that I saw this amendment so I want
to just make sure that that's clear
since my name was mentioned in the
context of this amendment numerous times
I do want to speak specifically at this
point about the warrant aspect because
respectfully I think whoever put it
together fundamentally misunderstands
when and how and what basis warrants are
in fact issued and what this amendment
does in fact is pretty much maintained
the ban that were dresses it up in
certain ways okay when an officer wishes
to get a warrant
against the person or to search a place
and it requires probable cause as is
mentioned here that means the officer
has to go to a court and establish by
probable cause a that the crime has been
committed and be that either evidence of
the crime is located in an apartment 3G
on Main Street or that this is such and
such a person is involved in the crime
and here's my probable cause so that's
what getting a warrant means now to use
the example the representative al
Shiller gave at our last working session
let's say a police officer has a seized
validly seized computer it has images on
it of what peers might be a child that's
in a lunar suggestive pose and that's
what they have normally now that officer
might well check the Interpol database
on Exploited Children to see if they can
find a match and thereby note who that
person is and what the age of that
person is that's how you develop
probable cause if you're saying the
officer has to go to a court first which
is what this bill says and go to court
to get a warrant and show probable cause
you don't have it all you have is a
picture that may or may not be evidence
of a crime you may not show a person
who's under the age that's relevant
there's a difference between a person
who's naked on a picture h20 in aged 14
so that's the problem with this you keep
you use the databases to get the
probable cause so you can't go to a
court with probable cause which is what
this bill would require now the feds
have been dealing with this say
issue I know representative oz chiller
passed around a letter by email
referring to a statement by a number of
police and prosecuting agencies offering
to work at the federal level on this
issue in fact more recently than that
letter that letter is back from last
October the feds have been looking at
the warrant issue and there's a proposed
bill the facial recognition technology
warrant Act which is bipartisan and it
says basically that federal officials
would be required to seek a warrant in
order to use facial recognition
technology to track a specific person's
public movements for more than 72 hours
the difference there is you have an
identified person you have probable
cause you want to sir you want to
surveil that person then you go get a
warrant this is what the compromise
looks like and that's what should be in
this bill rather than what is in essence
a a ban in a different way and I would
note for my friend representative hopper
that some food called Americans for
Prosperity
you've probably heard them they have
weighed in on it and they support the
federal view of what kind of warrant
should be gotten they do not support
anything that amounts to a ban and
they've been very public about that so
hopefully you know if this bill is ITL
now and taken up perhaps in another
session we can have all the stakeholders
come and come up with a warrant
requirement that actually works thank
you Thank You representative McGuire
then representative Griffin then
representative out
representative McGuire yes thank you
madam chair I I was in on the
conversations with representative Albarn
and hopper and the other individuals
that that were there included professor
sheriff from UNH and jean Houska from
the new hampshire ACLU the contrite to
simplify the bill and the intent our
real concern is that the state is not
that the state shouldn't use these
existing databases in the information
from them what we're concerned with is
we don't want the state to create
databases and use them so in my opinion
the most important element is the last
paragraph which takes the only facial
database in New Hampshire that in New
Hampshire government that I know of at
least and says you can't use face
recognition on that database because
that not only has faces it has a great
deal of very personal information that
we need that we need to protect and we
need to protect that now because it's
out there it is a without restrictions
it could be used by a lot of people to
identify most almost everybody in the
state and not just their face it's got
your address it's got your birthday it
probably still has some Social Security
numbers in there it's information that
we that we have that we very much want
to protect
I appreciate representative Burgess
comments on the search warrant issues
because that's something he knows a
great deal more about than I do but I
think that that's it's a deep I think
that is essentially a detail we say that
you need a warrant all right well we we
can work to develop a better definition
of a warrant
sorry but I think that for this year we
really need to protect our existing
database thank you
Thank You representative Griffin thank
you madam chair I do want to echo
representative Burch in regards to the
fact that this was a major change it was
an improvement I think to say that the
issue in regards to warrant is a detail
is problematic because the bill has
shown such substantial revision that it
looks like there were a lot of details
that rather than address specifically
have just been eliminated I am concerned
because this is a substantial revision
I appreciate this as how amendments
happen we get them an executive session
but there was substantial comment on
this bill and I think that more comment
on anything such as this amendment is
deserved I will note that if you google
face recognition technology a term that
was revised somewhat I would say
substantially from the original bill you
get a lot more definitions online and I
think we need to that in itself needs a
lot more fleshing out I do appreciate
that my comment about the motor vehicle
provision of this bill was addressed in
the Amendment and I did receive a call
from her from the Honorable Neel Kirk in
regards to this and that the provision
had been changed but I am a little
concerned to hear that for some people
at least the real purpose of this bill
was to address that database and if that
was the point of this bill then that's
what should have been addressed so I am
was not in favor of the bill and I
appreciate the work done on the
amendment but I can't say I've heard
anything that's going to make me vote in
favor of the amendment Thank You
representative al chiller thank you
thanks for unmuting agent so I would
like to also echo representative birch
and Griffin
I appreciate that the amendment
addressed some of the issues that were
brought up at the work session and it
shows that there are some a real will
towards working to put some guidelines
in place that address some of the issues
around facial recognition technology
that said in reference to representative
Burroughs question none of the people
who put the amendment together reached
out to any of the other stakeholders
about their input and I've had
significant conversations with
lieutenant parati from the New Hampshire
Internet crimes against children Task
Force and you know I I appreciate the
candor of representative Maguire at the
our work session and saying that her
group in a DNA did not make any because
did not take into consideration the
victim identification program or the
seva which is the child victim
identification program nor did it you
know take into account the sex offender
registry or any of the things that are
in place right now that we are using
right now that would be that would
essentially hamstring our law
enforcement from being able to identify
victims and I did hear from the New
Hampshire I CAC that they are on average
received 60 cyber tips a month and just
since the pandemic forced a the
quarantine in place their tips are up
threefold so this amendment and this
bill I get where we're going and where
we should be going but it actually
marginalizes a really vulnerable
population and I don't think that they
are served or our community is served by
further pushing them into the shadows
and make
even harder for law enforcement and
advocates to be able to get to them so I
think that this conversation should be
continued perhaps in the next session
and that those stakeholders should be
brought to the table and that it should
not necessarily just the one issue
advocacy organization that is driving
this conversation and that people whose
lives are affected immediately in a
negative way should be brought to the
table so that they have some input so
Thank You representative Woodbury wait
wait now you can go okay thank you madam
chair
you know I agree with the others who
just felt that this is a this amendment
is a substantial improvement and I
intend to vote for it and like many of
the people have spoken before me I I am
still of the opinion that this whole
issue is not ready to go
well go before the Senate go before the
governor and go before the public for
all the reasons that have already been
expressed one of my I have two concerns
and I expressed one of them the other
day one is that this bill doesn't really
solve the societal problem that we
really ought to be working on and that
is who who mounts the cameras where and
sees what and I think that would
certainly tickle representative Harper's
not funny bone but his sense of fair
play that we'd want we'd want to limit
that in a reasonable way so we don't
have a surveillance Society
this bill doesn't regulate that this
this bill nibbles around the edge of it
in a way that might have some marginal
utility but it really doesn't strike
home but getting back to this bill even
as amended I still have problems
although I think I understand it better
now with the language found on lines 26
through 29 and that
that's very important language because
it's an exception you know to the
general rule and you can expect every
case that comes up is going to rely on
that language and I get a kind of a
common sense idea of what its intended
to do but I think it requires an awful
lot more discussion to prevent you know
New Hampshire law enforcement and subtly
and with a wink and a nod and a nudge
nudge encouraging but under the radar
encouraging other states which do a
facial recognition to to cooperate with
us in a New Hampshire prosecution in a
way that might not be discoverable
I also have another issue with the
language of sufficiently attenuated and
then they give an example of what what
might be sufficiently attenuated but
they're clearly a whole bunch of other
situations that are not so defined and I
I feel uncomfortable asking a judge to
decide what's sufficiently attenuated
kind of in a vacuum so I think the whole
the whole business there's simply too
many loose ends that need a concerted
hard work to go forward with this and
you know basically I'm sympathetic with
with the general notion of what's going
on but we want to produce something
that's worthy of our efforts and right
now I don't see it so I intend to vote
for the amendment I think it's a good
amendment and it's well intended and
well met but the the idea of going
forward is not for me at this point
thanks thank you very much
representative horrigan wait wait wait
Tim until your can you run there now you
go thank you
of course some some people wish I'd
unmuted all the time but um well first
of all I think there is a this is mostly
the benefit of the by people watching on
YouTube if we weren't confused but there
was a reference to a hearing we
this committee actually you madam chair
waived the right to the hearing as you
meant to the beginning so that we
actually said a work session which is
slightly different from a public hearing
but and in fact I don't think any House
Committee has held any public hearing
I'm concerned about the term section was
sufficiently attenuated all the lines
from 21 to 29 seem very vague and I
think and I think it might make it very
difficult for any criminal prosecution
which involves video or still
photographs or even driver's licenses
because that combined with the blanket
ban on use of facial technology on page
two I think that I think defense
attorneys when they do which is uh and I
certainly applaud what they do you know
finding anything the law to get there
you know finally we can get to the
client it's off this might this might
make it impossible do they're difficult
to prosecute anyone based on video or
photographs because they could argue
that there's no way to prove that facial
recognition recognition technology
wasn't utilized to prove that the person
in the video is the same person that's
being prosecuted that seems like a
far-fetched theory so I think um this
amendment is less bad the original bill
but on its own merits I don't think I
could I could vote for them certainly
this is a issue which even if this bill
does not pass will we'll be looking at
it next year and probably for several
years thereafter so I'm I'm still
opposed to this amendment even though
it's you know it's an improvement as
others have said over the original bill
thank you very much representative
Wolper I think is next wait and see now
you can go thank you madam chair so I'm
going to take take these so first of all
in terms of what representative all
Shores are concerned about all the
actual usages and the importance of
using facial recognition technology
today I don't see anything in this bill
that would inhibit that any much of any
way if you got a chip that there's such
a
illicit activity the police begin their
investigation they have reason to
believe that there's an actual crime
they want to identify the victim that
shouldn't be a problem they should be
able to go to Anjali's very easily and
say look we're investigating this crime
we need to use this technology to
identify the victim and the judge will
say okay fine here you go
shouldn't take long at all and it
shouldn't it just shouldn't be much of a
hurdle at all even in the case of amber
Horace we we actually talked about this
when we were constructedness lenska we
had all kinds of language in there
trying to address the things that
representative also or listed both at
the hearing and again today but it came
down to all these things are still
allowable or allowed under this bill as
long as there's a good reason and that's
what the Lawrence of Art is it says you
have to have a good reason I don't see
why that should be a very big issue it's
a similar situation with with lions 21
to 29
mine's 21 to 29 are there to say we
don't the state if the state initiates
ill unlawfully the use of this
technology then that whatever it gets
out of that will be inadmissible but if
you can show that the data received
through this
that's paragraph 1 and 2 deals with
evidence by other people than the state
because number 1 says the state can't
initiate this in any way at all number 2
says if you get it from somebody else
and it has its it's not related at all
to the state's requests or anything like
that it's good it's just something
that's out there like we're talking
about with the international databases
then that's that what the sufficiently
attenuated is is intended to get at all
right if it's derived from other
sources have nothing to do with what
we're talking about that the states and
actual use then it should be still
admissible so and I think we've done I
think this really addresses all those
concerns as far as addressing every
concern to a specialist and recognition
software no and I we can't do that but
we can do this which is a major step
toward protecting the rights of our
citizens without burdening in any
significant way at all the opportunity
to use that technology for good purposes
we're planted whop are you finished I am
finished representatives hopper yeah
thank you and I appreciate
representative you know last last week I
fully expected you know representative
birch to throw me under the bus I just
didn't know you know representative
Griffin was going to jump in the bus and
back it up but now representative Harper
moving on so I don't understand that the
issue my understanding is that if a
police officer pulls me over and they
see something they find suspicious in
the back seat and they ask to search the
car and I say no they have to get a
warrant this is what this might be old
information and they call a judge and
they say they believe something's in the
back seat can I get a warrant they get a
warrant
I believe it only takes minutes I don't
understand why there would be an issue
if a police officer saw what he believed
to be a 12 year old girl in some video
how it would be cumbersome for him to
get a a warrant from a judge when he
said I believe this is a child that's
being abused and I get a warrant to run
her face through a database I don't see
why that's an issue and I think in doing
so we do protect a lot of people's
Liberty so that police officers aren't
just using the software arbitrarily or
willy-nilly so I don't get I don't get
the problem thanks representative
dilorenzo wait can you okay now well
thank you managed here there's a few
things that I'd like to say about my
thoughts on the bill
I think the amendment is an improvement
and I'm waiting towards voting for the
amendment but I think the bill as a
whole needs more work I did read the
Senate bill that is in the hopper down
in Washington and it looks like a really
good bill and the bill is tight if we're
talking about the same bill its SB 3284
introduced on February 12 2020 and the
title of the bill is ethical use of
facial recognition Act exactly a
commission find the use of facial
recognition technology and it brings
together you know stakeholders to really
hash it out and talk about a party and
that's what I feel like we should be
doing secondly I was initially
ambivalent about 1642 but after reading
the written testimony in opposition to
the bill I'm feeling that the brakes
must be put on unethical use of facial
recognition technology now for instance
a letter from a woman was representing
TechNet the voice of the innovation
economy and that group is a bipartisan
network of over 80 technology companies
that promote the growth of innovation
economy I sent an email to the executive
director Christina Fisher of TechNet
asking her for a list of the 80
companies that are involved and TechNet
and she wrote back to me and said that
she wouldn't have time to get all the
information questioned but she did send
a little blurb about the names of the
companies and I can go through the list
very quickly a paschal is very quickly
we're looking at Amazon Apple AT&T Cisco
Comcast credit common deltek eBay
Facebook GM Google Google Hewlett
Packard Microsoft Oracle PayPal you
Oberer Verizon and Beezer just to name a
few and it really concerns me that those
groups are in up those groups are in
opposition to on our 1642 and my god is
that they they're gonna make a profit
out of Facebook facial recognition
technology so they don't want it to beat
any brakes on it so that has raised my
apples and they're really concerns me
thank you thank you everything a perch
thank you I'll attempt to be briefer
this time in response to the last
comments I think there's ways to get to
yes eventually in this subject and I
think if we can get the stakeholders
together that we deal with here in New
Hampshire that that can happen and it's
one of the reasons I appreciate the
effort that has gone in so far on the
amendment to answer representative
hopper real quick if you go to a judge
with a picture and you say I've got a
hunch that this is a picture of an
underage kid you're not going to get
warrant unless you really like super
activist judges who's just going to
decide oh we'll just going to go search
anybody that the cop has a hunch about I
have a hunch there's drugs in that guy's
apartment I don't have any evidence but
I have a hunch you're not gonna get a
warrant that's the problem
finally I wrestled myself with whether
to vote for the amendment because it's
an improvement even though I'm
definitely gonna vote against the bill
I've worked in this field I've
represented individuals charged with
child exploitation I'm familiar with how
police investigate these crimes I'm
familiar with the databases and the like
and one thing I know is right now in
Keene detective McLaughlin is sitting
there on the telephone having
conversations pretending to be an
underage person with some pervert in
another state and those folks are highly
mobile they will come to New Hampshire
and they will get arrested they will
come to wherever they think they can
prey on a child and if the word gets out
that New Hampshire has the least
effective method for apprehending sexual
predators then I think we're gonna have
some problems and I can tell you I
wasn't elected by my constituents to
make it easier for people who sexually
offend come to New Hampshire and
potentially not have to worry as much as
in their home state so I'm gonna vote
against the amendment as well as the
bill Thank You representative Sylvia
thank you madam chair good morning nice
to hear your voice good morning first of
all I think I agree with the chair about
the
process of holding meetings via video
it's difficult secondly I think the
biggest issue having to do with this
face recognition question has to do with
databases and the databases that are
slurped up by our friends at Google and
Windows and Microsoft the Apple there
are databases all over the place they
are not state actors but frankly we are
almost to the point where it's really
hard to tell the difference
I find this troubling and I think this
is police state in the in the making so
I support this bill if we have to have
this amendment to pass this bill and
I'll support that but this is this is
very troubling stuff these databases
while we may think they're protecting
victims and children we know that
fellows like Jeffrey Epstein had access
to the highest government officials in
this country including presidents on
both sides of the aisle
not to mention Bill Gates these
databases are being accessed by the
worst of people and the database is the
problem facial-recognition we're to the
point where faces can be altered in
videos there are a lot of problems here
so I'm supporting this bill and if it
takes the amendment to pass it then I'll
support that too thank you very much
a representative well / thank you madam
chair I just said first of all I present
the implication from representative
birds that we're trying to make it
easier for people to be molested but
beyond that we're not doing that if we
got a plea if you get a police officer
and he's having a doing a sting
operation
and he identifies he's gonna identify
the perpetrator not the victim and I'm
understanding why what we're doing here
would make any difference in that
particular case even if the individual
came to New Hampshire to moist a child
we still wouldn't have a picture of the
child but if we did get a picture of the
child and in connection with that sting
operation then I can't imagine how it
would be very difficult even even
difficult to get a warrant to identify
the child or even the perpetrator
because there'll be huge amounts of
probable cause so I I'm just not
understanding and I hear this objection
over and over but I just don't
understand how those objections are
valid I just don't see it in terms of
representative or Jean Lorenzo and all
of those TechNet people those are all
private actors this bill has nothing to
do with them it doesn't affect what they
do what one iota so I still think it's a
good bill and in representing Canada
we'll address to begin to address what I
think is a potentially serious problem
and we see this problem in various
places around the world already well I
think we need to take action and should
do so now thank you
Thank You representative out Shore thank
you madam chair I just want to highlight
that this debate has has really brought
forth why it would be important to have
other stakeholders at the table for this
conversation and that the exclusion of
the New Hampshire Internet crimes
against children Task Force and the
exclusion of law enforcement and the
exclusion of crime victims advocates in
bringing this in having a say in how
this comes forward
is really really important because if we
because clearly I have not been clear
enough and eloquent enough to get that
point across and to make that understood
representative well / and perhaps maybe
representative birch has not been able
to explain that well enough to
representative well / but it would be
helpful I think if you were to hear
directly from the stakeholders for whom
this would have an immediate and
negative impact so that we could have a
conversation about what would be
appropriate guidelines for the use of
facial recognition technology so that it
doesn't impact current use through
databases like the C VIP and the VIP and
your being able to find out more about
those databases and how facial
recognition technology is used in the
identification of victims prior to
warrants being issued how those
children's exploited videos are passed
around and being you know manufactured
here in the state of New Hampshire then
that maybe we could write this in a way
that that doesn't hurt them at the same
time so I would encourage my colleagues
to to put a pin in this discussion of
overall not this discussion in this
moment but the discussion about facial
recognition technology for a time when
more stake holders can be present and
can give their input and are consulted
because one issue advocacy group is not
hitting all the marks for all of the
stakeholders that would be affected
thank you thank you very much and thank
you to all the members of the committee
who have chosen to speak up until now I
have a couple of comments that I would
like to make this
had a full and thorough hearing before
EDA it had a work session to which
everybody was invited so in those cases
there were many opportunities in
addition the members of the Judiciary
Committee each and every one of us had
the opportunity knowing that we were
having an executive session today to
come in with an amendment they could
have an amendment that says because this
is an important issue we believe that we
want to send this to interim study I'm
just making this up as an example they
could have an amendment that says this
could apply in situations except in
situations of child abuse child
pornography where they could have said a
thousand possibilities and no one came
in with an amendment except
representatives hopper and Welker no one
was denied an opportunity to come in
with an amendment so that if your
position is you don't like this bill
that's fine but if your position is that
you didn't have a chance to have your
views represented in the bill there was
a hearing there was a work session and
there was today where there were
opportunities for anyone and everyone
well anyone up until and everyone for
the hearing and the work session today a
amendment could only come in from a
member of the Judiciary Committee but
that leaves close to 2,000 of us who
could have come in with an amendment and
only two people did
as we all know I'm not a lawyer I don't
play one on TV I don't even play one in
the Judiciary Committee being married to
a lawyer for half a century doesn't
count I understand so I know a lot of
problems with the law on both sides on
all sides but I don't know a lot of
answers so I'm going to ask some
questions and perhaps somebody can
answer them for me let's do a
hypothetical the police doing their work
have images from a child pornography
video they want to identify the child in
the video they have probable cause to
believe an unidentified child is the
victim of sexual abuse and they believe
using facial recognition technology
might provide the identity of the child
is there a place in this amendment where
they would be prohibited from proceeding
to get a warrant or where they would be
prohibited where the judge would feel
that he could not grant a warrant okay I
don't see any hand so I'm going to go on
police have a missing child in custody
or have a picture of a child they think
is missing they want to run a picture of
that child's through the database to see
if there's because they have evidence to
believe the child is missing but the
child's lack of name or inability to
communicate might be because the child
isn't shocked the child is lying they
don't know but they believe this is a
missing child is there anything in this
I'm
that would say that they couldn't go to
a judge in that any reasonable judge and
not all judges are reasonable
just as not all lawyers are reasonable
that they wouldn't get a warrant what if
the police have what they believe are
unidentified human trafficking victims
they're victims of crime and they're
found in a house the police have
probable cause to believe a crime has
been committed committed and that they
will discover the identity of the crime
victims by running them through the
database can you tell me where in this
bill the police would not be able to get
a warrant and those are just questions
and I don't know the answers and I would
recognize representative birch thank you
madam chair you you kind of set it up by
saying I'll use your first example that
the police have probable cause to
believe that this child may have been a
victim
is there anything blocking getting a
warrant from a judge under this bill the
question is is you don't know that that
image is of a child just to start so
when you define it ahead of time is
saying there's probable cause you've
begged the question and you did it
really in all three questions you all
you have in essence is let's say a
photograph of a human being in a
suggestive pose you do not know if that
is a child or not and therefore you do
not know if there is a crime involved or
not and that's the first question you
may get from a judge that's why these
databases are so important because they
take all these victims of sexual
exploitation they identify them because
they just circulate on the inner
st. pictures or a lot of the same
pictures and they they figure out who
these people are and what their ages
because there's different issues if the
person is 15 person is 20 so that's the
problem in your various examples that
there there isn't probable cause I would
respond to that by saying I'm not a
lawyer I'm not a doctor I'm not an
anthropologist I'm not a social worker
or not lots of things but what I am is a
thinking I hope conscientious I hope
honorable individual and I like any
trained police officer looking at a
picture might not know if this person is
14 or 16 or 18 but they're sure going to
know if that person is six or eight or
ten or twelve and maybe a lot more
specifically than that they have reason
to believe perhaps using the word
probable cause
representative birch was an error on my
part because I deign to use a technical
word rather than just a word of an
ordinary Joe or Jane walking along
without that kind of professional
training but the examples I gave if you
did not want to immediately look to find
the weakest point I think I hope caused
us to think about the implications of
this I also do want to say that a number
of members of the the professional
police
cohort object very strongly to this bill
and to many others that come before the
Judiciary Committee because they say you
are trying to limit our power and my
answer to that and I'd stand up straight
if I could stand up and still have my
head before the the camera the yes that
is exactly what we are doing that is
what our job is to do in a democratic
society to make sure that we give the
police every tool that is necessary for
them to carry out their jobs and that is
responsible to help them carry out their
jobs but we recognize that there are to
be limits in a democratic society there
are to be limits I don't believe that
this bill does that but I understand
that a lot of a lot of you do and that's
fine I'm just saying that we ought to
look at the language and we ought to
look at the world around us and then
make the decision that you feel
comfortable with and you know those of
you who know me for two years those of
you who have known me for twenty know
that I will respect and support whatever
decision each of you makes and will
honor the differences of opinion because
these differences or what make it
possible for us to weigh alternatives
and try to come up with the best now
someone accused me of lecturing when I
did this at the end of the work session
I waited for an hour or more to hear
everyone else I hope it's not lecturing
when I take my chance to share my
thoughts with you and now I recognize
representative Woodbury
we okay okay yeah thank you thank you
madam chair just one thing I would raise
and I don't want to prolong this
unnecessarily but I hope I understood
your comments correctly but seem to me
in the examples that you gave the object
of the game and those examples were
simply simply to identify who the
victims were and it didn't seem to me
that the object of the game in those
examples was to actually find a
perpetrator and prosecute that person
now you wouldn't normally bring an
action in court where you'd have to have
admissible evidence against a missing
child if you just identified the child
and took it back to its parents but you
would do it if you use that information
to to prosecute somebody who causes the
child to go missing and I think that's
that's that's where this bill becomes
problematic I I don't want to I just
think we need to draw that distinction
and so that's it for me thanks thank you
very much anybody else okay I think we
have perhaps it was exhausted the
discussion represented welfare has
something he wants to add the adoption
of amendment 1255 representative well
per has moved the adoption of 2020 12:55
h is there a second representative
McGuire seconds the nomination
Anaka nomination sorry seconds the
woodies seconded the motion thank you is
there any further discussion on the
motion
ordinarily if we were in the same room
we would vote on an amendment by a show
of hands but under the requirements that
we face today because we are not in a
room we must take a roll call vote so
when the clerk is ready he will take a
roll call vote on the motion to adopt
the amendment
12:55 H to House bill 1642 and we're
waiting for representative Weber to be
heard ah now good there we go I have to
go back to the other window okay so the
move is a doctrine of amendment one two
five five representative Keynes yes
representative birch no well perhaps you
want to just do it the old-fashioned way
on paper and then enter it with artwork
um what it really takes is for me to to
know how to enter it right and I'm doing
it solo okay this won't take much longer
at all representative Oregon no in the
amendment no representative Woodbury yes
[Music]
okay representative all showing no come
on three representative delorenzo
representative burrows now
representative chase scroll coming down
representative Kenny now representative
wrangling no representative Stephens no
representative Harper yes
representative Silvia yes what's wrong
number
Oh cut it out what is going on all right
so you're all right now I'm sure I
should have done it the other way
why can't I just do it over you it's for
now the clerk boats yes okay I know my
represented Gordon not voting
representative jamaran yes
representative Griffin no forget how
many we got
representative McGuire
yes representative Alexander no I'm sure
yes that's right
so the vote being nine in the
affirmative eleven in the negative
attending the negative with one not
voting
okay I have eight eleven did I eight
eleven and one yes sorry
the motion fails on amendment
12:55 is there another uh excuse me
representative Horrigan did you or
something that's actually a procedural
question which this is probably I don't
know whether I should have should have
raised it now or after the vote but um
so we refer to at least two emails we've
received and those should be wooded
under normal circumstances end up in the
bill file and there were several other
emails that we read and thought about so
there so it's already means to make sure
that those are included in the file
just because I'm sure sure I'm sure
we'll have similar bills and future
sessions to people will want to go back
and look at the record of what well
thank you for the question under under
house rules and I have not seen any
indication that these house rules have
changed bills that are I mean excuse me
emails that are received do not have to
be put in the permanent record in order
to go into the permanent record
they are either hand-delivered which
cannot happen under this circumstance or
sent by mail and that is that is what
exists under house rules
I hear the point that you are making and
I am going to leave that to the staff to
determine how to resolve this problem
representative birch right now I would
defer doing that if either ever
Woodberry or representative out solar
wish to make that motion
representative Woodbury I thank you
madam chair I move ITL on the original
unamended bill is there a second
representative out shalour seconds
representative would Barry's motion of
ITL representative Sylvia I will be
voting against the ITL I think this is
the building of a police state and
Pinkerton did not kill mr. Floyd thank
you Thank You representative Sylvia are
there any other comments before we vote
on the ITL motion not see any the motion
is ITL on House bill 1642 and the clerk
may call the roll
House bill 1642 inexpedient to legislate
representative Keynes no representative
birds yes representative Oregon yes
representative Woodbury yes get over
there representative all show yes
representative DeLorenzo yes
representative burrows yes
representative chase yes
representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yeah
representative Stephens yeah how to do
that
representative Harper no cuz I better go
over there
chu representative Sylvia no puppies the
court votes no represented Gordon is not
voting representative orden represent
Gordon isn't here who's not absent oh
did I have to check the attendance sheet
representative Cameron no oh
are they get over there representative
Griffin yes
representative McGuire now
representative Alexander yes madam chair
yeah hi the vote has 13 6 1 how about 11
to 8
no well I don't know dead okay so yeah
what did you get Deborah I mean sorry
represent about you all the time
wait I have 12 seven okay so you got one
need nine ten eleven that only be eleven
twelve twelve was right one not building
seven okay so let's put that down here
okay I accept your no matter what I'm
sure you're right on the motion of ITL
passes this is probably I don't know
because I don't have a high enough pay
grade but it is theoretically possible
that this is the last time this
committee will meet on until the fall
when we have one bill on an interim
study I don't know that I'm not so good
at predicting the future but I want to
say that it has been an honor to work
with each of you and I thank you very
much and if in fact did the fullness of
time we are able to meet again I will
look forward to that thank you and be
well this at 11:31 I end the executive
session of the Judiciary Committee thank
you - thank you madam chair see you all
in June here yeah I will send a
committee report your way by email I
swim that's probably the only way it can
exist
yes I think so and then I will forward
it to the appropriate people Thank You
representative Boyd bird okay everybody
okay this is what a Minority Report be
do are you going to file a mine are
important I didn't ask you about that
yes both the reports should be we know
that we have a session on June on June
11th June 4th June 4th would be the next
hold on I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't
figure out how to get rid of that noise
the calendar when on June 4th would
include action on any bills that have
been taken so it would be great
representative McGuire if you could get
it in by say you know the end of
tomorrow over the weekend so that I can
send it on by Monday I'm sorry to
interrupt the important that the
Minority Report come from be authored by
a member of the committee yes I'm
familiar with that record they're going
and I completely forgot that thank you
I work with other members who voted in
favor okay thank you I completely forgot
that Thank You Jennifer
anything else just add it to the long
list of things I forgot okay thank you
thank you hope to see you all in the
11th I